à part la concernant le pass sanitaires
ça ça sera pour se rendre dans des
grands événements à ce moment plus de
1000 personnes ça permettra d'attester
soit une vaccination complète soit un
test négatif soit un test positif
récents comme quoi vous avez des
anticorps contre la copie 19
voilà cela sera nécessaire également
dans un second temps pour pouvoir
voyager au sein de l'espace heureux le
pauvre sein de l'espace européen à
partir du 1er juillet il ne sera pas et
bien nécessaire pour les enfants de
moins de 11 ans et il sera indispensable
jusqu'au 30 septembre maximum pour
l'instant c'est les chérit les 10h58 on
est bien sûr en direct sur ces 8 à
nouveau parce sanitaire ouverture des
restaurants fermeture des restaurants on
est là ouais alors oui c'est vrai on est
là laurent les actions de merci d'être
là bonjour de plaisir et d'un poste et
c'était chaud hein ah ben oui boutry m'a
traité de criminel pc pro vaccins ce
n'était pas très gentil
je sais je sais mais déjà il ya déjà des
gens qui ont été plus câlins avec moi je
sais si vous parlez de bernard montiel
on comprend au niveau ligue massue bâle
a foulé soir maintenant mon haut niveau
livide et lé hier soir il y avait ce
soir il a fait un petit rafraîchissement
capillaires s'était battu merci déjà
bout de d'avoir accepté notre invitation
comprenez vous ce qui parle d'atteinte à
la liberté quand on parle de passes
sanitaires gilles verdez ou dit oui bien
sûr
deux raisons d'abord parce que c'est de
la discrimination ce qu'ils ont ce
qu'ils n'ont pas on ne l'a pas on peut
pas entrer au spectacle on peut pas
aller dans tel ou tel mais là dans un
stade et donc il sert à quoi votre passe
alors c'est aussi un peu sanitaire
j'étudie n'importe où
laissez moi finir dans une chose quand
vous le montrer sur l'illustration et
benhaim on dirait qu'elle avec son mari
dans la voiture est atteint
les données les données vont être
transmises par tous on nous met en
données donne mais sur un téléphone les
gens partout on va être espionnés ça va
partir par tous on est plus libre on est
plus nous-mêmes deuxième oui mais karl
lagerfeld 110 comme gilles je vous fais
partie d'un mouvement pour faire telle
ou telle chose du quotidien on est
obligé d'avoir un pass sanitaires oui ça
porte atteinte à notre dignité au
quotidien et ensuite par le passé le
passé une cabine moi c'est rogner le
secret médical on va savoir qui est
vacciné qui n'est pas vacciné qui
dessert on va savoir qui est malade et
n'est pas malade on ne semble pas en
phase avec les autres virus c'est tout
mais on le sait déjà
alors oui ça me gêne ou pistache
alors il ya de choses ce n'est pas un
passe vaccinale il veut dire que donc
soit tu es vacciner si tu as envie de
l'être si comme jean par exemple tu n'as
pas envie de l'acte tu fais ton test pcr
situé négatif qui a aucun souci malabo
par ailleurs tu parles du quotidien
c'est pas pour le quotidien
si tu veux les faire tes courses n'a pas
besoin de se passe si tu veux aller au
restaurant tu n'as pas besoin de ce
genre si tu veux aller dans des
rassemblements qui ont plus de 1000 5000
personnes
et là on le joue il s'agit de la santé
publique parce qu'on n'est plus depuis
2000 où 5000
moi ça me semble plutôt de j'allais dire
de du bon sens c'est à dire que dans
notre vie de tous les jours
n'y a pas de souci quand on est dans un
endroit nous y ait un risque
et bah ce moment là on essaie de se
protéger les uns les autres voilà c'est
mon raisonnement
volley-ball et flic c'est quoi ton vrai
prénom est oui olivier tu vois pas qu'on
soit pour pas qu'on
mais je suis en attente alors il vaut
mieux lire avant de donner mon avis
parce que là la fois j'étais avec
laurent alexandre et j'ai eu beaucoup de
retours sur les réseaux sociaux il ya
beaucoup de gens en fait qui vous
connaissais pas et si vous voulez savoir
un petit peu qui vous êtes donc j'ai
regardé un petit peu donc laurent
alexandre quand même par rapport à
toutes les paroles que vous donnez très
très proche de nathalie mais n'a là vous
avez aussi dit que bill gates était le
plus grand héros et vous avez ainsi
aussi annoncé qu'en 2050 les personnes
qui n'auraient pas un qi de 150 ne
serviront à rien c'était juste quand
même pour que les gens puissent
comprendre un petit peu qui vous étiez
là n'ont pas laissé raymond de laurent
ruby 1400 n'a rien que ces pays il a
donné toute sa tortue satisfasse à sauve
dix millions dix millions de dollars il
a laissé à ses enfants
mais il reste honnête et les petits
africains donc effectivement c'est mon
père on vous avait déformé ce que j'ai
dit mais le compromis
j'ai dis qu'effectivement dans le futur
face à l'intelligence artificielle il va
falloir que l'éducation nationale fasse
des efforts parce que sinon on a des
gamins qui auront du mal à être
compétitif face à l'intelligence
artificielle et je maintiens donc et le
fait que que choix me avec jacques
attali il n'y a que les antisémites qui
me le reproche est monsieur vinolas bana
bana là c'est un mec sympathique un
génial qui peut déconner il ya deux ans
n'est d'accord c'est pas le sujet mais
mais mais mais benalla sujet monde au
final ait ahmed mahrez saint geoirs et
est là et on choisit passé on choisit
pas ses amis au smic quand on a un ami
une chanson à un ami aurait vu la part
de l'un quand il a des difficultés face
à la justice
on reste amis avec les gens même quand
ils ont découvert deux manches
judiciaire ça c'est vrai que je
n'abandonne jamais mes amis même quand
ils ont le juge au cul et ben au moins
vous fait au moins un point de discours
non avec bernard montiel
vous voyez sur une passe à niteroi pas
sanitaire sérieux c'est le pas de la
contrainte ont fait un petit peu
aujourd'hui moi je pense qu'il serait
peut-être temps d'arrêter de contraindre
les citoyens et aussi laisser travailler
que ça soit les restaurateurs les
barmans les gens du spectacle parce que
ils ont très très souffert de cette
crise et aujourd'hui il faut il faut
leur laisser de l'oxygène c'est pas
possible
pourquoi mille pourquoi pas 2000
pourquoi pas 3000 qu'est ce que c'est
que cette histoire ça veut rien dire
pourquoi 23h pourquoi pas une heure du
matin
pourquoi la mairie appelle le mille
bornes alors dans ce cas là ce que je
veux dire s'il sait que c'est
complètement idiot ça sert à rien moi je
pense personnellement et ça n'engage que
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement essaye d'apporter d'énormes
contraintes à travers les déplacements
et tout ce qu'on pourrait faire dans la
vie quotidienne et aujourd'hui on a beau
on se rend compte et je rappelle je suis
pas un anti vaccins les gens qui veulent
se vacciner qui se vaccinent il faut il
faut laisser le droit à chacun de
pouvoir faire ce qu'il veut est-ce que
ça c'est super important et c'est mon
combat mais en apportant des contraintes
comme ça au quotidien
on essaye de faire vacciner un maximum
de personnes qui est qu'ils ne voulaient
pas se faire vacciner que moi je
rencontre beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui
qui me disent tu sais olive
ben j'ai fini par me faire vacciner
alors que j'avais pas envie mais parce
que je veux vraiment retrouvé la liberté
de circulation et de pouvoir me déplacer
et moi je je finirai là dessus ce qui me
fait vraiment peur j'ai peur que si la
traverse à le gouvernement n'arrive pas
à vacciner un maximum de personnes et on
le voit un petit peu ce qui est lancé à
la télé aujourd'hui j'ai peur qu'on en
arrive à une boîte six nations
obligatoire et ça me fait très très peur
surtout pour nos enfants
patrick mais moi je suis je suis
cheminées du truc est ce moi je suis
artiste moi j'ai envie de travailler
c'était là on devait faire un truc dans
le nord et c'est le préfet qui a décidé
qu'on ne faisait pas sur quelle base je
ne sais pas ce que je veux dire aux gens
qui nous regardent moins s'ils veulent
me prendre pour faire la fiesta les
médecins et tout avec du monde créée par
mills va fé départ mais je fais le
permis c'est la personne va du petit peu
leur chaut qu'on fait avec le hockey
savent les danseuses d'habitude c'est
5000 10000 personnes sur une place
serrés les uns contre les autres
apparemment cela fait peur moi ça me
fait pas peur moi ça me fait pas plus
haut rang et le pass annie terre ça
serait peut-être une garantie d'abord
attendait pas finie dab d'abord
c'est lui qui m'a demandé c'est faux 90
2 cuill c'est la faute des séries la 88e
m'intéresse pas je sais pas mais comme
disait coluche intelligence on est tous
persuadés d'avoir eu ces faits que c'est
vrai que ça qu'on juge
on est tous persuadés d'être
suffisamment intelligents je ne pense
pas que ce soit là je pense pas que ce
soit là mais la meilleure référence je
préfère l'intelligence aux humains de
l'intelligence du coeur que
l'intelligence pure ça c'est un autre
débat
ouais je te disais le le les gens qui
viennent dans les galas c'est vrai que
si tu te sens plus en sécurité si les
mecs ont fait un test négatif s'ils sont
vaccinés etc
tu sais que tu peux aller au contact tu
parles de privation de liberté ça fait
longtemps que nous a privés de plein
plein plein d'autres libertés
je pense pas que ce soit une des plus
essentielles maintenant moi je respecte
chacun si qu'ici il ya des risques à
prendre ta vu que cette épidémie est le
grâce à la vaccination d'après ce que
j'ai compris je sois complètement idiot
mais elle elle baisse en ce moment on a
il ya personne ici qui a envie que ça
reprenne dans le gisement non trois mois
moi je me suis fait vacciner parce que
j'en avais envie je suis d'accord avec
toi ce qu'a fait ce qu'il ya autour de
moi qui veulent pas je trouvais que
c'était une bonne solution
quant au passge suprême je suis vraiment
merdé parce que je joue je voudrais pas
que les gens aillent faire ce truc là à
un moment faut repenser parce que là
c'est bon le soleil brille et c'est un
paquet de mecs qui sont morts un paquet
de mecs qui ont souffert qu'ils ont été
très malade et c'est ce qui doit les
faire un concert et que tu ressors et
que pendant une semaine que moi ça me
fout un peu les jetons quoi j'ai pas
trop envie moi pendant toute cette
période j'ai vachement fait attention
même encore les gestes barrières les
machettes ou créés ainsi pas envie
déchets jamais qui fait du boulot chez
moi qui est mort [ __ ] c'est en cinq
jours ça ça me fout les jetons j'ai pas
envie de mourir de ça c'est important
que des pas mourir de sa la raison je
pourrais je veux bien mourir avec mon
coup de rouge vêtue message veut pas
jeux jeux bacall je vais mourir à cause
de la sir est parce que je fume trop
j'ai choisi patrick ya plus d'échangés
de mourir du tabac le ring du cowboys je
sais je sais je suis mais on peut mourir
de tous là maintenant tout de suite
c'est pour ça que rire des mais le truc
dans la bible
le truc de la liberté moi je crois que
la liberté est les bouffer sur tellement
d'autres choses tellement c'est un vrai
combat rhin on en a parlé tout à l'heure
je suis bris mais t'es pas brimer le
laurent alexandre on parle du pass
sanitaire comprenez vous ce qui parle
d'atteinte à la liberté
laurent alexandre se passe à dire c'est
une bonne chose ou pas ça des mariés à
minuit c'est une bonne chose puis on
voit bien qu'il ya plein de choses qu'on
peut faire maintenant d'abord le
couvre-feu est à 23 heures pile bientôt
sauter on peut aller au restaurant
librement sans pass sanitaires il ya
plein de trucs qu'on peut faire sans
pass séries terre d'infos faut quand
même pas charrier le pass sanitaires il
va avoir une utilisation très très
limité sur moi ça me fait rigoler les
gens qui nous explique qu'on est en
dictature a d'abord c'est rare dans les
dictatures on puisse expliquer qu'on est
andy nature et puis franchement tous les
mecs qui explique qu'on est en dictature
avec le pass annie terre je propose
qu'on les envoie en stage 15 jours à
cuba ou en corée du nord qui voit ce que
c'est une vraie dictature comptons entre
louvres on est au gnouf pendant cinq ans
je pense que les gens devraient un tout
petit peu avant de parler de dictature
sanitaire aller voir ce que c'est qu'une
vraie dit les nationaux viennent de
là-bas je ne pense qu'à cuba on peut
prendre le soleil dans les camps de
concentration pour les prisonniers
politiques mais en corée du nord il fait
très froid donc cme se gênent les miches
un peu ça pour dire que franchement dire
qu'on est dans la dictature sanitaire au
moment où on est en train de se libérer
petit à petit c'est pas raisonnable sur
le coût du vaccin
ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est que si on
n'atteint pas 70 75 % de vacciner on va
avoir une nouvelle vague à l'automne
chez les non vaccinés
quand le temps va refroidir et quand on
va changer de saison donc aujourd'hui au
lieu de raconter partout qu'on est en
dictature sanitaires il faudrait que les
gens se fassent vacciner pour qu'on soit
définitivement libérée du coc vide et
qu'on n'ait pas une quatrième bague
delphine alors il ya deux choses il ya
le pass vaccinale pour ça bonsoir et ça
s'il était obligatoire serait
catastrophique jusque là c'est une
privation de liberté et il y a le pass
sanitaires oui mais pour ça il ya le
pass and i ter et dita von teese est le
problème avec ce guillaume clément
cousin que j'aime
que j'aime donner on est bien comme tu
disais le problème c'est que le pass
sanitaires on va savoir qui est malade
est pas malade
des spéciales où il ya quelque chose à
filmer des coupures tous que tunisie et
janry te dire encore heureux parce que
c'est comme ça qu'on va pouvoir endiguer
l'épidémie mais mais le pass sanitaire
obligatoire pour les événements depuis
2000 personnes on va pas tous les jours
dans un événement de plus de 1000 cas
ici au pire on n'est pas vacciné tu te
mets le cotonou et nature je veux aller
avec au niveau liste de ce qu'a dit
laurent alexandre quand il parlait de
ceux qui parlent de dictature web alors
je pense que c'est toujours un mot très
très fort et c'est vrai que qu'il faut
arriver à trouver un petit synonymes et
je pense qu'il ya différentes sortes de
dictature quand les gens parlent de
dictature aujourd'hui c'est parce qu ils
sentent leurs droits et leurs libertés
de parole et d'expression en fait
diminué diminué sur les choses par
rapport à certains médias et puis la
censure qui est terrible sur les réseaux
sociaux
et ça y va à fond de train surtout
autour du colis je regarde par rapport à
ce qu'elles sont aujourd'hui en fait sur
les réseaux sociaux il ya une énorme
censure qui est fait je pense que la
liberté d'expression passe sur le fait
de nous on peut exposer une façon de
penser sans avoir des postes supprimés
ou des comptes fermés
malheureusement aujourd'hui c'est ce qui
se passera la raison au tour est de plus
en plus avec le co vide il ya une
accélération des choses autour de ça et
on n'arrive même plus en fait à exprimer
sa fratrie luxe qui est d'accord il a
raison vous savez qu'aujourd'hui sur un
réseau social vous mettez un poste avec
le mot vaccin qu'ovide et c'est à vous
avez une espèce d'avertissement en bas
donc ça déjà pourquoi on comprend pas et
pour revenir sur ce que disait laurent
alexandre oui on porte atteinte à notre
liberté puisqu'on en train de
culpabiliser les gens en leur disant
vous estimez vous heureux là vous pouvez
sortir ou pour aller jusqu'à 21h dehors
etc afin d'être ailleurs
23h02 aujourd'hui d'accord c'était 21h
encore hier et excusez-moi alimentaire
voyager aller en boîte de nuit c'est
vivre aussi il n'ya pas qu'eux
vingt jours la céni retraites c'est pas
fini ensemble des masques a pris 20 juin
c'est fini c'est pas bon ça m'a
totalement libre je suis désolé c'est la
vie d'avant par rapport à ce que vous
disiez on a on nous annonce à la
télévision qui avait une accélération en
fête du conte vide dans une région de
france est la région la plus vaccinée de
france à 43 % de taux de vaccination la
nouvelle aquitaine comment vous
expliquer qu'une région la plus vaccinée
de france c'est là où ça redémarre et
c'est là qu'on a une montée une série
très bien ce qui se passe sans nouvelle
équipe tiennent en à 1 kloster d'un du
variant indien qui est beaucoup plus
contaminant que les autres et qui se
diffuse plus vite donc pour un même taux
de vaccination on a plus de cas quand on
a des variantes du virus qui diffuse
plus en plus contaminant donc ça
s'explique extrêmement bien on a vu ça
dans d'autres pays
effectivement quand il ya un variant
plus méchant ou invariants qui diffuse
plus vite et bien on a effectivement une
augmentation des contaminations mais
franchement je pense qu'il faut un tout
petit peu revenir à la raison
bigard comme tout le monde le sait a dit
à dick le pass le pass sanitaires
c'était la nouvelle étoile jaune donc il
a comparé la politique sanitaire de
macron à la politique contre les juifs
cependant pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale je pense qu'il faut être
raisonnable oui on a une limitation de
nos libertés pendant l'épidémie
elles sont en mer dans témoin de palais
au resto ça m'a emmerdé mais d'aller
jusqu'à dire qu'on est en dictature ou
que c'est l'équivalent de l'étoile jaune
c'est totalement déraisonnable je leur
ai dit que toi tu l'as dit mais biggar
l'a dit des tas de gens l'ont eu en
outre ils ont dit
comparer le pass vaccinale avec l'étoile
jaune franchement c'est laurent il me
semble c'est honteux c'est honteux c'est
honteux c'est honteux c'est dégueulasse
olivo libre qu'est ce qu'a pensé de cet
été aux sur la sphère france it à la
pensée de quoi de la faire pschitt
haleine avec quotidien avec l'équipe de
journalistes était là-bas alors je suis
arrivé là bas une heure après en fait
sur le faire sur sera pas l affaire
francis lalanne qui aurait voilà
monsieur un caméraman de quotidiens et
un les solistes qui c'est quoi la vraie
version bas la vraie version allait
vraiment pas belle à entendre la séance
aujourd'hui on entend les gens pas de
voiture je vais te dire quand j'ai vu ça
et j'ai francis elle une aussi j'aime
beaucoup
madame ou la série qui voit là il y des
choses sur les quais
je suis d'accord avec lui sur rien du
tout mais là franchement je sais soutenu
à fond l'équipe de quotidiens d'air
parce que voilà si celle ci s'est passé
ce qui s'est passé qui les a agressés
encore là alors c'est pas le cas alors
c'est pas le cas alors premièrement à ce
jour d'ailleurs il ya aucune vidéo qui
montre qu'il ya eu une attaque physique
ouverte envers le caméraman mais aucun
témoignage d'ailleurs moi j'ai reculé
mois des témoignages des gens qui
étaient autour c'est maintenant et c'est
son témoignage il y était donc l émoi
hier jeudi journaliste de l'aps non mais
alors que je pense que ça va vous
intéresser bien ce match j'ai même lu
dix mois d'été mais ce qui est
surprenant cyril c'est qu'on a un
journaliste pour un cameraman qui dit
qui a été victime d'agressions physiques
qui sont partis et que le soir ils ont
constaté à trauma crânien et une
blessure au poignet moi tu sais cyril
suis arrivé une heure après tout ça mais
une heure après l'équipe de quotidien
est revenu et a travaillé jusqu'à la fin
de l'après midi et j'ai même fait une
interview avec eux personne n'était
blessé ça traumatisme crânien parfois on
peut ne pas le sentir je te jure
rolivalois poignée enfin poignet presque
cassée comme on a pu l'entendre non pas
celle ci même si c'est possible
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est quoi la
version que vous avez il a accepté
l'interview de quotidiens au départ
lalanne
il accepte on est là on me l'a relaxé
l'interview n'a vraiment pas besoin
non c'est vraiment une terre nous caler
d'avancé juste demandé à ne pas être
filmés c'était l'interdît au départ je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi aujourd'hui
ça s'est passé mais ça aurait été un
autre citoyen ç'aurait été la même chose
quotidiens ont des agissements
aujourd'hui avec de la manipulation et y
trompent les images et il trompe les
gens qui parle je peux vous donner une
anecdote très simple ils ont faire un
reportage avec ingrid courage que je
connais très bien qui est une chanteuse
engagée et tout au long de ce reportage
ça se passait très bien ils font des
caresses dans le dos et ce qui s'en suit
est contre ce reportage est sorti ils
ont fait passer pour la pierre qu'on
cotise du monde ils l'ont sa vie salies
le problème c'est que j'avais une
déferlante après sur les réseaux sociaux
cette femme a reçu des menaces de mort
en disant je viens de voir le reportage
sur quotidien et quelqu'un a marqué il
faut tuer cette bonne femme pascale et
dangereux grave parce qu'il ya eu une
manipulation d'imagés une manipulation
de parole voilà pourquoi quand les
équipes de quotidiens aujourd'hui se
déplace à certains endroits et bien il
ne
sont pas acceptés et puis ça peut monter
crescendo aujourd'hui c'est francis
lalanne ce que malheureusement je
condamne ce qu'a fait francis est vrai
et si les a achetés les mêmes molesté
mais je vais vous dire aujourd'hui bien
il ya un vrai truc aussi c'est que quand
quelqu'un ne veut pas parler il faut le
laisser tranquille aussi oui mais un
moment parce que je vais vous dire après
ça va être les escalades et oui je veux
dire il va se passer des trucs très
grave et même pour la vous dire pour
l'intégrité de certains journalistes qui
vont prendre des risques inconsidérés
sur des sur des dessertes de sujets il
faut leur dire si le mec faut pas parler
tu ne la jetterait casque n'a pas encore
sa majorité ou étudier parce que francis
voilà ça va pas que se termina la jolie
alors vous avez enlevé au gainage à
berlin je suis évidemment contre la
violence mais pardon mais sur ce coup-là
il cherche un peu la merde ils viennent
interdit voire de force francis lalanne
qui n'a pas envie de se voir ici déjà
les gens ce cas là on a eu le même
problème avec gilles bien déjà avec les
personnalités qui sont dans la rue
d'accord s'ils se font emmerder et qui
finissent par bousculer n'est pas ce que
parce que ça les agace et mafia c'est
inadmissible tu peux lui dire on n'en a
pas l'habitude une fois deux fois trois
fois ci la calade comme à metz et vous
font de sous-entendus dégueulasse avec
bigard en sous-entendant qu'il a fait un
appel au meurtre et donc du bigard et
moi j'ai trouvé ça bien pour moi il
soutient ses amis comme l'avait prédit
patrick swayze une énorme connerie mais
valence et si on gagne au prix goncourt
nadine si superman et vous arrêtez ça
valait la tôle à duke au vide
sur nos six ans pour dire que bigard ne
parlait pas de ça s'il est utile par les
badauds nettoie johnny par les
bas-rhinois nous menacer la paix demeure
au regard d une crème si crème bizeray
voilà moi je sais pas si ces microbes
buzyn non mais de tout près donc voilà
mais c'est vrai que l'admission mais
c'est un antisémite a également réservé
admissibles oui bah oui il faut les
raccourcis dégueulasse non seulement il
entend vous le mec contre son gré ils
font des raccourcis dégueulasse pardon
mais c'est normal que le mec pète un
câble et on attend d'avoir sauvé le même
discours qui risque jusqu'à ce qu'il a
fait ou pas non non et un cyril
d'ailleurs si tu veux des témoignages de
gens qui sont autour je te donnera les
numéros de téléphone parce que avec
plaisir monsieur renseigner quand même
des choses je suis jamais quelqu'un qui
annonce des choses sans même renseigné
d'accord et c'est ce que j'ai fait je te
donnera les ch'tis c'est pas fini de la
terre est ce qui s'est passé c'est que
les journalistes le quotidien sont
arrivés et francis a très vite compris
qu'en fait il y avait encore une
manipulation d'imagés il savait très
bien que c'est qu'ils valaient en venir
dès lors a tout simplement dit je ne
veux pas être filmés arrêter cette
interview je ne veux pas vous répondre
parce qu'ils savaient qu'ils allaient
encore mélangé les mots et les images et
ils sont restés et moi sincèrement je
pense qu'il ya eu peu je sais pas il ya
eu une bousculade où il s'est levé puis
le caméraman a peut-être trébucher ou ce
qui s'en suit voilà vous avez en été sur
un regroupement où il y avait beaucoup
de citoyens en colère des gilet jaune et
ce qui s'en suit vous savez tous très
bien que mon film beaucoup
s'il devait y avoir des images ça ferait
longtemps qu'ils compensent les
téléspecteurs sur la liberté d'attentats
liberté 60% sanitaire comprenez vous ce
qu'il rate d'attentats liberté 60 mon
sens comprennent et 40 % non mais